welcome back to drew's news we are here
with the beautiful the talented the
goddess of goop gwyneth paltrow
[Applause]
all right now your show sex love and
goop is all about experts giving advice
to people in need so many different
diverse subjects and layers and we
wanted to get you in on our little
segment called ask a desperate
i said it you did it i'm so proud of you
in honor of your show all of our
questions today are focused on
relationships let's kick it off with
kathy who's here today kathy what is
your question
so i have a friend who makes horrible
choices with men wow
so
should i tell her that this guy is
unworthy of her or should i just let her
live and learn gp will you kick this one
off because i'm dying to know what you
think
so here's the thing
she's recreating something a dynamic
from her childhood unconsciously
through her choice of partners that
she's trying to heal right we all do
this unconsciously we all
go back to the more difficult
relationship that we had with a parent
which everyone was more difficult
and i'm gonna pick somebody who's really
unavailable or really ambivalent and i'm
going to win them over i'm going to show
them that i'm worth being with and we
don't know that we do this but we do
this like we do it over and over so
as opposed to saying i think this guy is
why am i cursing on tv i'm so sorry
this is your house you do whatever you
want the red carpet is rolled out for
you to infinity and beyond continue i'm
so sorry so i would maybe say
you know i wonder if i could talk to you
about an observation i have around
the types of men that i'm seeing you
choose because it seems to me as your
friend
that you are
in relationships which are making you
unhappy and this is this is the pattern
that i'm observing
like are you open to talking about what
might be happening and what you might be
recreating and how do you is this a
pattern you want to break and if it is
let's talk about it
honestly that is really sound advice
kathy and i were looking at each other
like she's an expert that is that is the
well we wanted to swim in brilliant
advice brilliant so
all right uh you're good at this gwyneth
so we have another one for you this
comes from michelle on twitter who
writes my new boyfriend wants to try
role playing and dressing up hey
but but i don't feel sexy doing that how
can i let him down gently without
killing the mood so if you've got a
partner who's into some stuff but you're
not into that what do you do
well this is actually
i would really recommend them watching
sex love and goop and
there's a there's an expert on there her
name's jaya and she essentially
um
[Music]
created something called the erotic
blueprints where you can go on her
website
and you take a quiz and you under you
can understand more about your erotic
blueprint so what can happen is a lot of
times in very loving relationships
people's sexual blueprints can be really
different so
really important to understand and have
an open and honest conversation about
what you like
and get comfortable
with the difference that your partner
might have and sometimes even a
conversation and saying you're safe like
whether you want to you know play dress
up or not i love you
um
sometimes lets people go well maybe i
will try that or you know because
they're not threatened and they don't
think that they're unlovable on some
level like they've just had a very
interesting honest open conversation
about what might be possible and then
the concentric circles of what's
possible sort of expand wow
i i'm trying i was trying to picture if
i had an
exotic
or erotic
erotic blueprint yeah
i don't know
all i can see is it looks like like ikea
instructions i'm just confused
so i need i don't know quite how to
translate it so i do think about it
you gotta go you gotta go on the website
and take the quiz ross i wanna know what
your blueprint is oh oh girl
we should take it oh okay do we have to
share it
i'll take it i'll go down
i want to take it but i highly suggest
the show for her because that question
was taylor made
for your show thank you michelle um all
right we have time for one more question
ivy how can we be of service
so i have been dating this guy for a
while like six months and he hasn't
locked it down yet so i want to know how
to have a conversation of talking about
dating other people not complete leaving
him back but you know it's so easy for
men to date multiple women at the same
time but i feel like it's a double
standard for a woman to date multiple
men at the same time and be open about
dating those men so i want to know how
to have that conversation with him all
right
go droops what were you going to say
well i feel i don't know why this came
to my head immediately i think you need
a backup plan for if you ask him if he's
seeing other people and if he says yes
for it not to be a shocking moment
to sort of be able to handle
that answer and sort of not go to defcon
5 in that moment um okay because that
can cause that it's like it's because
she had the conversation with him
without asking that question i mean
couldn't couldn't she theoretically say
set up the conversation to say hey you
know this feels like it's going in the
right direction and i have a lot of
respect for you
and you know up into this point whatever
but how do you feel about making uh a
commitment of monogamy like are you open
to having that discussion is that what
you want i don't even know if it's what
i want can we have the conversation like
make it feel really collaborative i
think is the way as opposed to leading
with
something he could hear as
disappointment or jealousy i don't know
yes yeah can i just put this out there
that you're all better than i am here's
what i would do
you are good people i'd be like hey
listen up someone else just asked me out
should i go or are we a thing
[Applause]
well
i
just would be in this trio any day of
the week this is indeed
i mean literally this is a neapolitan
ice cream sandwich that i could eat
all day long thank you gwyneth paltrow
[Applause]
i love you this show is a revelation
thank you for putting it out there i
think it's a game changer it's streaming
now on netflix get it while it's hot
[Music]
you